welcome welcome to another exciting
edition of Market takes we are looking
forward out at the week thank you so
much for being with us know you could
have been anywhere in the world but you
were here with me and I appreciate that
I'm Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal your host for Market
takes and look there is going to be a
lot happening this week we got a huge
week of data but I'm going to tell you
what the three most important things are
that are happening this week uh first
things first the first one is inflation
we get two big reports on inflation this
week CPI and PPI I'll tell you what
those are what you need to look for in
those second we will be hearing from the
IMF the international monetary fund and
the World Bank on the state of the
global economy I'll tell you what to
watch and listen for throughout the week
of meetings as well as what reports are
going to be coming from that third we
will get the first earnings reports from
the largest U.S banks that's coming on
Friday that's going to tell us a lot
about not just the economy and the
Market but that's going to tell us a lot
about this bank run these Bank collapses
that we've been seeing this movement of
money across the banking system we're
going to hear from those big Banks and
we're going to learn a lot about what's
going on with the banks and how that
looks Through The Eyes of those Banks
and what that could tell us that's going
to tell us a lot about the economy so
listen let's get into it first things
first inflation out this week we get the
CPI the Consumer Price Index I want to
put this chart here up on your screen
that's just gonna it shows you what
we've seen from CPI now going back to
March 2022 where we start this you saw
inflation had already picked up and and
there was an expectation that okay we'd
hit Peak inflation but then nope you see
it picks back up there and then in June
we hit that 9.1 percent number and ever
since then we've been coming down coming
down coming down and economists predict
that inflation for March for March 2023
will be about 5.2 percent now that's
down from six percent in February and
down from 6.4 percent in January you see
that just continual decline of inflation
on the CPI and that just illustrates
this chart up here shows you how
inflation has consistently come down
over the past year it's done that month
over month as well economists predict
that we'll see 0.3 percent inflation for
March that's after point four percent
February and point five percent in
January now one thing you want to watch
out for when we get this CPI report is
the core CPI number that strips out
volatile food and energy prices and
that's going to be a big number because
economists actually expect that to rise
now overall inflation you saw in that
chart had been coming back down and
economists expect that to continue but
core stripping out volatile food and
energy prices is expected to rise for
the first time since September that
could be big because it could alter what
the Federal Reserve is thinking and how
they're looking at inflation you're
going to want to watch out for that also
important within this CPI report is
going to be the movement of gas prices
we have seen gas prices the average
across the country has was new about 360
per gallon and out in California it's
approaching that five dollar per gallon
average throughout the state so oil
prices start to pick back up the decline
in oil prices has been a big part of why
inflation has declined it's been a big
part of why consumer sentiment has been
rebounding and now we are starting to
see those gas prices pick up we're
seeing oil on the market at about eighty
dollars per barrel uh Saudi Arabia and
OPEC announced a surprise cut in
production that could push gas prices up
you're going to want to watch that now
the other thing you're going to want to
watch out for this week CPI comes out on
Wednesday Thursday we get PPI or the
producer price index want to throw that
chart up here on your screen to give you
a look now PPI has really LED CPI it's
been about a month ahead and we've seen
the trends now you see there that same
kind of trend but you see things moving
higher on the PPI report June was over
10 around 11
PPI inflation that's what businesses are
paying producers uh it's AKA what this
pre this report is also known as the
wholesale price report so it's what
businesses are paying for labor their
inputs all those things when they go out
and buy and then they turn around Mark
the prices up and sell them to us so
that's been a leading indicator of what
overall inflation will be for consumers
that's expected to decline to 4.4
percent in March so again as it led CPI
going up it's now expected to lead it
has led CPI coming down that's expected
to continue so this chart just
illustrates what we've seen for business
prices the PPI over the last year and
that trend is expected to continue one
thing that I think has been really
interesting is you know while inflation
is still very high compared to
historical Norms or at least the Norms
over the past 20 years it seems like a
lot of folks aren't really talking about
I want to put one more chart here up on
your screen and this is a chart of
Google Trends and this is just how many
people are searching for this compared
to how many people searched for it
historically you see that big pickup
there in August that's that giant Spike
you see that's actually after the big
peak in inflation that happened in June
and ever since then it's been just kind
of consistently declining look inflation
is not over inflation is still very far
from the fed's two percent Target it was
at six percent we saw in February even
at 5.2 percent of economists are correct
we are still a long ways from two
percent so that chart up there just
illustrating kind of a an interesting
theme that I'm seeing which is folks not
really being worried not looking up not
Googling inflation that's definitely
something to watch out for also we are
going to get the fomc minutes the
minutes from the fed's last policy
meeting those are out on Wednesday as
well along with CPI definitely something
to keep your eye on we'll be right here
Wednesday morning 10 a.m Eastern due in
Market takes breaking down that CPI
consumer price index report on inflation
I hope you'll be with us as well the
second thing you need to be watching out
for this week is the IMF and World Bank
Spring meetings those are going to kick
off this week we've got the world
economic Outlook released on Tuesday
that's the imf's big picture look at
what's going on with the globe and of
course the economic Trends in the last
update in January they said they saw a
quote turning point for Global growth
they raised their expectations improved
the Outlook now overall Global growth is
expected to slow from 3.4 percent last
year to 2.9 percent this year we'll see
if they revise that maybe there's an
even Rosier Outlook but the one thing
that you worry about with a Rosy Outlook
is that could show a pickup for
inflation definitely something to keep
your eye out on uh previously had the
World Bank has warned of a quote lost
decade for Global growth especially in
Emerging Markets talking about how
things like the war in Ukraine the
covid-19 pandemic and of course High
inflation have impacted the overall
theme of how the globe can grow they're
saying that you know the potential
growth from 2000 to 2010 have been about
3.5 percent then from 2011 to 2021 that
it dropped to 2.6 percent now the
expectation is that that potential
growth output will shrink to 2.2 percent
when there's not as much growth
businesses can't grow as much incomes
can't grow as much folks aren't able to
build their wealth as much and you see
things just kind of get worse for
everybody we had seen a long-running
trend of continual poverty alleviation
wealth accumulation poor countries have
been growing a lot richer and that's a
bonus for everyone around the world
including us here in wealthy countries
like the US Europe Japan things like
that that's been slowing down and that's
definitely something to watch out for
big picture when you look around the
globe also worries about inflation
potentially coming back definitely
something to keep your eye out on for
these IMF and World Bank meetings coming
up this week that kicks off on Tuesday
with the wio report as they call it
World economic Outlook then Wednesday
you got the big meeting IMF managing
director christelina georgieva World
Bank president David Malpass look out
for that finally the third thing that
you need to be watching out for Bank
earnings we get those starting on Friday
the big names JPMorgan Chase Wells Fargo
City BlackRock PNC Bank bny Mellon the
trillion dollar teams they are all going
to be out with their reports uh this
week not all of them have a trillion
dollars in assets just a couple of them
just so I don't get any emails because I
know y'all like to talk but those big
banks will be out with their earnings
reports on Friday this is going to tell
us a lot about this worrisome banking
crisis banking collapse Bank Run
whatever you want to call it how much of
that money flowed into these big Banks
from some of the regional and smaller
Banks we hopefully will get some
information on that and what does this
tell us about the state of the banking
sector are these Banks doing something
useful with that Capital are they saying
okay we're moving into more risky assets
that might be something worrisome to
watch out for you know and this is
overall going to tell us how are they
feeling about this deposits remember I
told you guys a while back Banks don't
want your money the big Banks they have
enough money they really don't even know
what to do with this money crazy problem
to have but it is one the big banks are
having they got too much money now they
got even more what are they doing with
it we're also going to talk about how
much they accessed how much the big
Banks access the fed's discount window
did they borrow a lot of money from the
FED we've seen 400 billion dollars in
increase in the feds balance sheet how
much that went to Big Banks 5 finally we
are going to see their loan loss
Provisions how much of the big Banks
worried about losing money on loans are
they putting a lot of money to the side
and saying okay we think a lot of people
aren't going to be able to pay back
their loans that's something to look out
for Hey listen that's going to do it for
us here on Market takes I appreciate you
guys so much for being with us I am Dion
rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me I thank you for that we hope
you'll be with us on Wednesday and we do
it again next time on Market takes
foreign